monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères alors que l'europe peine
encore à trouver une sortie collective
organisée et raisonnable à la crise
migratoire crise migratoire historique
qu'elle traverse de nouvelles
interrogations émergent
à force d'inaction parfois même de déni
de réalité
la question migratoire n'a pas été gérée
comme nous l'ont d'ailleurs rappelé les
oubliés de la croissance
les perdants de la mondialisation dans
ce contexte particulièrement tendu de
nombreux français découvrent le pacte
global pour les migrations sur ordonnée
et régulière porté par l'onu six pays
d'accueil pays de transit et pays
d'origine peuvent au moins ça corte sur
le titre dudit pacte
il reste que le contenu et la méthode ne
laisse pas d'interroger voir d'inquiéter
car le texte sur lequel s'engage notre
pays n'a rien d'anodin les signataires
ils prennent l'engagement de réaliser 23
objectifs déclinés en près de 200
mesures spécifiques dont la mise en
oeuvre sera en outre surveillées par un
mécanisme de suivi et d'examens comme
souvent les inquiétudes sont balayées
voire même méprisé par les tenants du
pacte qui présente les esprits
sceptiques comme mieux mal renseignés ou
empire mal intentionnés de plus la plus
élémentaire des réflexes démocratiques
aurait dû être deux pour le gouvernement
d'informer la représentation nationale
de ce projet et d'en débattre avec elle
avant de prendre définitivement position
dès lors monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement at il conscience qu'en
procédant de la sorte qu'ils contribuent
à un affaiblissement démocratique
renforçant le sentiment que les peuples
n'ont plus leur destin en main
pour vous répondre la parole l'état
jean-baptiste lemoyne auprès du ministre
europe des affaires étrangères monsieur
munich
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur pour
cette question qui va permettre de
rappeler alors qu'un certain nombre de
rumeurs d'informations fausses circulent
sur ce document ce qu'il contient
exactement
c'est un document dont le préambule dit
qu'il est qu'il réitère réaffirme la
souveraineté des états à établir leur
politique migratoire
c'est un document qui vise à rappeler la
coresponsabilité entre les états de
transit les états d'origine les états de
destination est donc ce document qui
d'ailleurs a un caractère non
contraignant c'est écrit noir sur blanc
ce a été rappelé par le secrétaire
général des nations unies antonio
guterres s il a comme vertu d'être une
boîte à outils dont les états peuvent
s'emparer pour faire face à ce défi
mondial parce que ce défi on ne peut pas
le résoudre tout seul et le gouvernement
a pris soin naturellement d'informer le
parlement
j'ai d'ailleurs en main le texte qui a
été transmis au sénat le 25 avril 2018
au titre de l'article 88-4 de la
constitution puisque en effet le la
commission européenne souhaitait
également approuvé le pacte est donc ce
document depuis six mois
il est à votre disposition il aurait
permis si vous l'aviez souhaité que le
sénat émettent un avis sur ce document
voilà je pour autant
faute de réaction de la haute assemblée
je me suis néanmoins pencher dans les
travaux de la commission et je constate
que le 30 novembre dernier une
résolution européenne du sénat sur les
conclusions de la commission d' enquête
sur schengen et monsieur reichardt a
beaucoup travaillé sur le sujet rappeler
un certain nombre de principes et invité
le gouvernement à s'y tenir
je les cite la coopération approfondie
et fructueuses avec les pays d'origine
et ça tombe bien c'est
aux fondements du pacte également la
nécessité de négocier avec les pays
tiers sur le retour et l'admission ça
tombe bien c'est l'objectif 21 du pacte
donc c'est bien fort de votre
inspiration que le gouvernement s'est
rendu à marrakech pour approuver ce
pacte monsieur allizard oui monsieur le
président merci le monsieur le ministre
de cette réponse mais je crois quand
même que dans le contexte
particulièrement tendu que nous
traversons et les dernières semaines
viennent de nous le confirmer
les français en ont assez de la
verticalité comme mode de gouvernance et
ils veulent plus d'informations et de
démocratie un état aussi qu'ils prennent
leurs responsabilités et dès lors je
crois qu'il n'appartient pas des experts
de se substituer aux élus nationaux et
de préparer en sous mains des politiques
publiques et je crois qu'une politique
on va résonner une intégration réussie
de migrants nés en conclure autre chose
que ces belles paroles